who knew that the cure to the dagestani
wrestling
were the Aussies were the Aussies uh
okay let's go there
the uh your your friend your training
partner Alexander volkanowski you helped
him prepare for the Islam marketev
versus volkanovsky fight who do you
think first of all won that fight
that's a tricky one how is that the
tricky question I will say when uh when
I was a [__] talk you've been doing
how's that
when I was in the corner going into the
fifth I personally believed live that uh
vulcanovsky probably needed a a finish
to take the victory but you have to
think that way right in general or you
like legitimately it's a gray area
because the judging who knows plus I was
like where we're in Australia where's
this bias you know we've got some
Australian judges here I was really
hoping we give it a bite unfortunately
not hopefully they lose their jobs but
again yeah it was it was a close one I
think sometimes you're blinded in the
moment because again everyone counted
vulcanovski out the crowds behind him so
everything he does is going to get a
huge cheer your bias towards the smaller
guy you buy us towards the underdog so
you sort of whatever the underdog does
has a bigger impact in your mind and
sometimes they can bias as the fight
goes along but yeah super super close
fight I got I would really love them to
have a rematch but obviously that's
going to hold up both divisions so I
don't know if they'll be able to do it
do you think they'll do a rematch soon I
mean that wasn't that was an epic fight
I was listening to the fight companion
during they all thought uh so they
biased strongly the the opinion round
two was the the tricky one yeah yeah
round two is a tricky one anyway I'd
love to see that like uh running back
and do three actually there's an epic
fight uh what was the brief conversation
you had with Islam marketev and his team
I didn't know how to take the truck
because obviously khabib tried to fly an
eagle kick Dylan Dennis in the face so I
wasn't sure how my humor would go yeah
but I mean Dylan must have said some
worse things to me I was just playing
around I mean you can't really take
anything I say serious yeah come across
like an idiot but so what he was coming
up to me afterwards I was like oh I
don't know what he's gonna say and again
maybe he would have been more upset if
he had lost but he just received the
judge's decision yeah but he came up I
went to check he's saying he gave me a
big hug and then pretended to throw me
and then I thought the interaction was
over and then he circled back so that's
why I was so awkward I was like oh he's
coming back he wants to say he wants he
wants something else but he just said
why didn't you teach your boy how to
escape the body triangle oh wow
interesting what did you say to that I
said well I mean obviously you've got to
learn how to finish a real naked choke
is that what you said
uh and I was laughing but then I should
have said they were like get out of here
before the Aussie crowd attacks here you
know what do you think about the body
triangle position that we're in it
seemed like for the first time it seems
almost like walk was yeah it did
dominant in that position which is kind
of weird I mean damage is meant to Trump
control
MMA judging damage is the number one do
you think the the judges saw that who
what do they score that as I think they
all scored four towards Islam yeah three
and five uh two of the judges scored
towards Volks one of the judges scored
three for Islam one it was 49 46 uh for
one of them and the other ones were 48
47 I think they're
again the confusing round was around so
I don't think anyone scored the body
triangle round for Volks which I wish
they had
uh volkanowski was and is still arguably
Palm for upon greatest fighter in the
world how long have you known him I
don't know the first one I met him
before he was in the UFC when I used to
live in Melbourne he came down to train
it absolute yeah and then we really
connected on Ultimate Fighter he one of
his guys who's going to bring told him a
fighter barbadell pulled out last second
so he called me when I was in Puerto
Rico and he's like do you want to coach
on tough for five weeks and like I said
Puerto Rico was Apocalypse Now I was
like yeah get me out of here so I took
jumped on that opportunity and we were
in Vegas five weeks together because he
was meant to fight Ortega and then he
got hit with covert real bad
uh got stuck in I think he was in
hospital for maybe one to two weeks and
then before he flew back to Australia
they were like all right maybe we just
do you guys as The Ultimate Fighter
coaches so I jumped on board with that
and that's really when we've become
close yeah obviously I was useful in the
Ortega fight help him get out of
submissions
he fought then Korean Zombie Max
Holloway I basically just held the
bucket at that point in the corner a
couple striking uh fights and then again
yeah we had to tackle the Islam problem
so I did spend five to six weeks down
there preparing for that how did you uh
tackle the Islam problem
was you somebody who barely knows
anything about wrestling having to
obviously doesn't take much you know
yeah especially Russian wrestling uh did
the beard help or like what like in all
seriousness what were some of the key
ideas you that you worked on with
volcanovski to prepare for it I had the
help of Frank Hickman Hickman was down
there too one of the Hickman Brothers uh
wrestling coach so we were sort of like
problem solving and I mean basically we
were confident in Volks uh fence
wrestling his cage work he's super good
on the catch super like uh
under respected in that position and we
knew that if we were able to take the
scrambles to the cage he would be
effective against Islam because again
Islam is background of [__] Freestyle
Wrestling but I mean honestly he's
probably got the same experience on the
cages folks obviously some of those uh
wrestling skills would translate very
well to the cage but the cage is still
somewhat of a gray area an equalizer
involves again incredible ability to
stand up incredible defense on the cage
which you saw we worked on strategies to
get up and a ton of submission defense
Islam loves Kimora's obviously reenactor
from the back arm bars those are sort of
and Armstrong was dominant submissions
but again the guys he submitted
not grapples
apart from Charles Oliveira and again
Charles Oliveira was basically knocked
out at that point so I was still
impressed if he submitted him but again
I always told people this they thought
it was crazy I was like Charles Oliveira
versus Islam in a grappling match
Oliveira is going to win that match
like submission grappling submission
grappling yeah so if you were grappling
skill set I think Oliveira is a more
dangerous Grappler so we didn't even
come into it thinking Islam was this
Unstoppable Boogeyman that people make
him out to be
so we approached her from that just
focused on the techniques
ability to get back up using Turtle to
get back up using Turtle to scoot to the
cage to get back up and hand fighting
from there keeping it pretty safe but
what makes Volks so special I think is
his gas tank gas tank and his willpower
he's just unbreakable the dagestani guys
khabib Islam they are good at
submissions but okay they break guys
mentally and they fatigue him and then
they take the submission that's offered
Oliveira is a guy that can jump on
submissions and have an incredible
technical ability to finish those
submissions whether you're fresh or
you're tired and then you combine that
with falconowski who incredible
willpower never gets tired you're never
going to break him and as you saw he
only attempted one submission the whole
fire is that learned is that trained or
are you just born with that that mental
toughness it's a good question I mean
he's like an anomaly like the entire
fight Camp not nervous at all supremely
confident the whole fight week
completely confident he just has an
attitude like oh everyone cast me out
we'll see you know what I mean Islam
he's like let's see no doubt no doubt at
all super relaxed up until about five
minutes before and then he starts
stamping himself up he's like you are
not taking this belt from my family gets
into that sort of mindset he actually
says that out loud
you can't teach that survival he didn't
even take a fight you know
have you guys ever been like pushed to
the Limit like that or broken in a
grappling match
I'll do it in practice like I'll push
myself to like you know I think it might
pass out or die or something like as far
as like uh how tired you get you know
because like in a match
um they try not to ever get close to
that anymore yeah you try to because you
know it's important to understand uh
where you're exhausted exhaustion point
is
um but yeah if you have to push to that
limit imagine probably do doing
something wrong you know like if you
like you've seen matches where guys
Sprint the last like minute they're
trying to win the match in last minute
and it's like you definitely had some
mistakes leading up to that if you have
to you know gonna go boss the wall
okay but has there been other times in
competition especially like early on
because you're like you wrestled pretty
hard and wrestling is pretty exhausting
like not wrestling but you know
wrestling style kind of thing going
against the best people in the world
yeah I mean I definitely again I think I
think in practice it's important to uh
do that hard work that where competition
is is much easier you know I think if
you if you Redline in practice and you
really push through like death's door uh
then once you're in competition and
you're working with you know you're
being fresh in a compliment
it's much better have you ever been to
that thing where Dan Gable talks about
always wanting to be to a place where
you can't get off the mat
like you work so hard in the training
room you can't get off the mat I think
he says he's failed at that in his
career he was always able to at least
crawl off the mat
yeah I definitely never like actually
died on the map but I felt like I felt
like I was gonna die you know sure uh
what about you do quit all the time I
get a lot of cramp I'm like you know
what you got me man let's do this again
tomorrow
dude if I'm asking Craig for a role he's
in the bathroom somewhere
do you do you see the value of pushing
yourself like to that place where you're
knocking on dust storms yeah but within
safety you know because obviously the
most uh serious injuries occur when
you're tired of training and stuff like
that so I think like taking a page out
of what those MMA fighters do especially
Volks with his training like he's not
necessarily pushing crazy in each round
but he's doing extra conditioning
assault bike stuff crazy workouts
outside
and uh he does do some crazy training
workouts but all safe very safe like
when he's redlining like that in the
training room it's a very controlled
safe setting I think to do that in Jiu
Jitsu against some of these lunatics out
there that are trying to kill you
especially when you have a name can be
dangerous so your approach is just as
don't warm up and don't try too hard
no sir no for safety though yeah
longevity you know and talk [__] to
about Russians I got it I got it I hear
you oh you mentioned uh cage work what
what what's interesting to you that
you've learned overall this time about
cage work what's like what's interesting
about the Dynamics of that are you
talking about both like the control
in the dominant position but also
getting up from the bottom while you're
against the cage all of that the added
dimension of that cage that wool being
there changes a lot of stuff right so
obviously in some ways it's a much lower
Impact Wrestling style because he can't
be thrown on you can shoot the cage is
going to block their feet you're going
to be able to chase down their hips it's
just a completely different fight and
again because of Islam's Judo skills
that upper body controls you see he's
able to use against the cache like the
inside trips uh sort of the YouTube
artist style all right Goshi throws so
obviously those skills do translate but
yeah I think the cage is a great
equalizer for a lot of things like
athleticism and stuff it takes away a
huge speed Advantage uh aspect of the
fire so he's really good at staying up
what is is there I assume he learned all
that from you and your instructional
just stand up I mean we were so
confident I was like you know what why
don't we put this thing out a month
before the fun yeah maybe the illegal
download hasn't made its way to Russia
yet yeah but it was there for him can
you can you explain to me what's in the
instructional just stand up like what
what are what are the ideas what do you
I mean the old school way to stand up
people to talk about the technical get
up you know the old Gracie put the hand
but I mean that's that doesn't work
hasn't worked for 20 years you know if
you look at everyone that gets up in MMA
they're using Turtle to get up they're
using wrestling together you know what I
mean yeah which is uh counter to what
pure Jujitsu says they say don't expose
the back don't ever expose your back I
think Jiu Jitsu is a terrible way to get
back to the feet because if you were to
retain guard and go half got a close
guard super hard positions to get up
you're basically putting yourself in a
leg tuck for wrestling so I think you
need to borrow from wrestling to learn
how to get up in an MMA fighter so
basically how to safely expose your own
back while not allowing them to get
Hooks and use that to get back up or at
least not allow them to get two hooks
and that applies for MMA especially for
MMA especially because obviously uh
striking is a factor but if they are
striking they don't have locked hands
around your body means you are able to
move you are able to make an attempt to
get back up they have to choose between
control submission or strikes
uh post from Reddit why does Craig Jones
push so hard for a bottom is bad jiu
jitsu what is so bad about playing
bottom guards such as half guard or
delegio those are the two options no one
likes the bottom why would I want to get
up
it's the question for all of you is is
the bottom a bad place to be I mean the
Bottom's bad if you don't want that guy
on top here that's the way I look at it
you know that's that sounds like
something a cowboy would say but I don't
know if it has much meaning I think the
point of jiu jitsu's both are dangerous
being on bottom and on top I think the
longer the match is probably the
favorites the top guy more just because
every movement the bottom guy makes is
probably carrying your your weight
carrying that gravity on top of you so I
think it's a bit more efficient uh
passing from the top as opposed to
sweeping from bottom Bottom's reactive
top is active the top player just saw
it's how to engage how to approach the
god that can use angles they can use
footwork that can throw people uh throw
the legs by so it's an active position
Bottom's reactive reactive you're gonna
get fatigued yeah I think I think it's
very difficult to gas somebody out while
playing guard uh but I think it's very
easy to gas somebody out uh when
attempting to pass it well you guys are
talking about guessing people out but is
there are more dangers from the bottom
like in terms of submissions and all
that kind of stuff or no I'm back and
forth because I'm a top I'm a top player
but I understand the value of being on
bottom like when I do play guard bottom
I feel like this the submissions come
much easier uh and when I'm on top uh
they come also pretty easy but uh maybe
I just take a different route
it's up on the straight spot them in the
shades
what was the hardest part of the
training for the the training camp for
volcanowski like you're just
experiencing world-class MMA fighters
training and giving your approach of the
Jiu Jitsu of not trying to harden no
matter what yeah I mean from my
perspective there's a lot of pressure
for that you know like that's a that's
that's a lot of pressure for me to go in
and think that I could possibly figure
out a way to help this guy address this
guy that's basically never been beaten I
think he got knocked out once but
basically not really even been put in
bad positions you know I mean it says a
lot of pressure on me especially because
volcano see such a great guy yeah Jiu
Jitsu is different you know like you
coach a guy who loses he has time to tap
but they never make it gets severely
hurt yeah there's a lot more weight and
what you need to do as a coach you have
a greater sense of responsibility to the
health and well-being you know like
obviously I know Fox kids I know his
wife you know what I mean they're
putting faith in you to not just win the
fire but keep this man safe you know so
from my perspective a hell of a lot more
pressure
uh coaching him as an MMA fighter it's
almost like the psychological aspect of
like um
of doing the best he can for him exactly
yep yep what was uh what was the hardest
about the actual training was it the
technical aspect of trying to figure out
the puzzle of Islam or was it like being
a good training partner in the in the in
the like in figuring out how the
grappling would work basically playing
your best impression of microchip were
you trying to actually impersonate him
like not not just uh visually but like
in stock yeah definitely definitely
visually you're not as good looking but
go ahead a little taller but uh no in
terms of the training yeah I mean Islam
is known as incredibly strong glass
obviously I'm heavier than Islam so
theoretically I should be able to
replicate that strength difference and
then in terms of grappling targeting
those submissions that Islam does like
focusing on those in the training room
focusing on the way he holds half God
and really [__] in the grappling sense
trying to replicate him on the ground
and then yeah I wrestled with him on the
woo a ton trying to replicate obviously
it's the best one ability a lot of the
stuff he does on the wall body lock
heavy inside trip uchimatas and just
constantly uh put in the work on Volks
you know what I mean like constantly
chaining attacks against him
really replicated as he's trying to get
up and escape and all that kind of stuff
so this submissions like both Judo and
submissions just attacking attack
exactly and there's only so much you can
do really because obviously he's been I
think he's been fighting a long time so
it's like you're trying to polish what
he already is good at you can't just
completely create an entirely new game
for him in the space of six weeks so
you're trying to take what he's already
effective at add to it and luckily a lot
of the stuff he's already very good at
was easy to add to for the for the fight